hi mystery recapped here today I'm going
to explain an American Horror science
fiction film called Bird Box spoilers
ahead watch out and take care
[Music]
the movie begins as a woman named
Mallory Hayes gathers her children and
informs them that they are going out on
a journey the two children whom she
calls girl and boy quietly listen as
Mallory explains that they will be
rowing through a river for several days
the plan is to reach a secluded house in
the forest where they can meet other
friends but there's one catch during the
entire trip they will be wearing
blindfolds and if the children take them
off even by mistake they will be in
trouble after the instructions Mallory
leads them outside whilst being
blindfolded she also brings along her
pet birds soon they reach the bank of a
river where a boat is waiting for them
Mallory tosses it into the river jumps
in with the kids and Begins the journey
following this the movie flashes back to
five years in the past Mallory is an
aspiring artist who is eight months
pregnant she recently got divorced and
is still struggling to cope with the
post-breakup stress one day as she is
busy painting her sister Jessica arrives
with some news she mentions that while
she was at the department store every
everyone was stocking up on groceries as
the thing is approaching them Mallory
who has been disconnected from the world
after the divorce is unaware of it so
she turns on the TV to her surprise all
the news channels are reporting about a
mysterious outbreak that has ravaged
parts of Eastern Europe the symptoms of
the virus are very strange anyone
infected will immediately want to commit
the unthinkable the virus apparently
takes control of their brain and turns
them into monsters however Mallory
doesn't take it seriously thinking that
the outbreak is far from the U.S Mallory
has never heard of airplanes after a
while Jessica takes her to the doctor at
the hospital the family physician Dr
lafan conducts some tests on Mallory and
inquires if she is ready to be a parent
Mallory hesitates for a moment before
saying yes on the way back she Witnesses
a strange sight a woman is continuously
slamming her hat on the glass pane this
makes Mallory realize that bath salts I
mean the outbreak from Europe has
arrived in the states so she rushes
outside and explains to Jessica that
they have to get home immediately
however by the time they prepare to
leave pandemonium has already set in
hundreds of people have become infected
and are attempting to end themselves one
way or another cars are colliding people
are falling and other shocking events
are taking place this thing is spreading
faster than stupid Tick Tock challenges
Jessica steers her car through the chaos
and it appears as if they will reach
home but suddenly her eyes become still
and she starts staring into something
that only she can see Mallory tries her
best to bring Jessica back to awareness
but to no avail the next second the car
gets involved in a deadly accident the
sister somehow managed to escape
unharmed but unfortunately Jessica who
is still in shock commits the
unthinkable Mallory doesn't even have
time to mourn as by this time the city
is turned into some sort of a war zone
people are dying left right and Center
Mallory tries following some people to
safety but she trips and falls to the
ground seeing her struggle a woman
leaves her residence and tries to help
Mallory despite her husband protesting
against it unfortunately her decision
turns out to be fatal as the evil entity
possesses her the woman stares at the
invisible entity for a while and then
walks inside a burning car soon it
explodes killing her on the spot
following the horrific encounter Mallory
has finally helped up and rushed into
the house by a man named Tom there are
several people inside the house
including the owner Greg his friend
Douglas and the Machine Gun Kelly hi
what's up in the next scene everyone
gathers in the main room and discusses
the supernatural entity that has been
wreaking havoc throughout the world a
grocery store worker Charlie theorizes
that it is the end of the world While
others believe that it is an act of God
at this point though everyone is aware
that the entity is Untouchable and that
staring at it will result in their
demise meanwhile Tom consoles Mallory
who is still distraught over the
untimely demise of her sister an hour
ago she was living a happy life free of
problems and stress but now the world
around her has turned upside down later
the entire group gets together and
Boards up all the doors and windows they
want to make sure that no one peeks
outside back in the present Mallory and
her kids have been on the boat for six
hours now at times they cover themselves
with a blanket so that they can take off
their blindfolds Mallory tries her
walkie-talkie to check if someone's
nearby but all she can hear is the
invisible entity Whispering her name
back to the past Mallory and the other
survivors have started coexisting in the
house one day a Survivor named Olympia
arrives at the door and begs to be
allowed inside Douglas refuses but the
others eventually persuade him to let
her in when Olympia enters it is
revealed that she is also pregnant later
Greg comes up with an idea he decides to
inspect the CCTV cameras to see what's
going on outside the others are
skeptical about the idea but none of
them objects soon Greg sits in front of
his computer and observes the footage
suddenly he notices something and
instantly freezes it appears as if the
entity has possessed him after a while
the others hear a loud bang from his
room and when they rush to inspect they
find Greg lying in his own pool of blood
this makes them realize that the entity
can possess them even via the computer
so they destroy it immediately in the
present it's been 14 hours since the
family has been rowing in the river now
suddenly Mallory hears a man's voice
saying it's okay to take off her
blindfolds realizing that the person
might be infected she orders the
children to stay low and keep their
blindfolds on soon The Voice which
appears to be coming closer mentions
that he has food he also claims to have
seen the entity which he describes as
friendly just then he lunges towards the
boat but Mallory is prepared she strikes
him with a machete and finishes him off
in the next scene we are again taken to
the past where the group has run out of
food since help is unlikely to arrive
Mallory Tom and a few others decide to
travel to a nearby department store
where Charlie used to work they cover
the car windows with black paint and use
GPS to direct them in the midst of their
Journey the GPS begins to beep violently
indicating that the entity is nearby
however Tom manages to get them out of
Harm's Way and into the store the group
immediately rushes inside and stocks up
on whatever they can get their hands on
meanwhile Mallory notices some pet birds
and decides to take them home the group
is almost done Scavenging when suddenly
a guy starts screaming from the freezer
he mentions that he has been trapped
inside here for days and food is running
out Tom and the others buy his story and
open the door and at the same time the
birds start making noise it seems as if
they can sense the possessed people
nearby the man inside the freezer
suddenly changes his behavior and starts
acting like a demon Tom and the others
try to hold him inside but the man seems
to be just too powerful realizing that
everyone will die if he comes out
Charlie sacrifices himself to rescue the
others that night as Mallory and Douglas
are discussing in the kitchen they hear
a noise from the garage unfortunately
Machine Gun Kelly and his girlfriend
have escaped with their only vehicle I
gotta go find my boy Travis yo this
place is toxic peace back in the present
the family has spent 24 hours now on the
river Mallory has become so tired that
she ends up colliding the boat against
an old truck this results in the boy
tumbling into the river along with all
their supplies fortunately Mallory
rescues the boy and docks the boat near
a Shore she then warns the children to
stay put before heading inside the woods
to look for supplies using a thin rope
she locates an abandoned hospital where
she collect some food items and clothes
as Mallory hurries outside the building
the entity can be heard calling her name
meanwhile at the shore the little girl
becomes anxious as it has been an hour
since her mom laughed so she disobeys
Mallory's orders and heads inside the
jungle to search for her unfortunately
the entity starts talking to her
suggesting she remove her blindfold and
see the Green Forest the little girl
becomes convinced but right before she
can do it Mallory arrives and takes her
away together the three then get on the
boat and resume their journey in the
next scene Olympia allows a suspicious
looking man named Gary inside the house
the others are livid that she took the
decision without consulting with anyone
nonetheless they examined Gary and let
him stay after a while he claims that
there are other people outside who are
not wearing blindfolds they have somehow
learned to coexist with the entity
everyone trusts him except the old man
Douglas who brings out his gun and asks
him to leave however he is quickly
subdued when Greg's mom Cheryl knocks
him out with a vas the group then locks
Douglas in the garage afterwards Olympia
profusely apologizes for causing all the
trouble and being a burden but Mallory
reassures her that she did nothing wrong
as the two pregnant women Bond they
promised to look after their children in
the event that one of them dies Mallory
even gifts Olympia a Hello Kitty toy is
a baby shower gift in the present the
little girl is holding the same toy
which reveals that she is Olympia's
daughter Mallory wraps herself and the
kids in a blanket as they approach the
Rapids warning them that this will be
the most dangerous part of the journey
she then mentions that one of them will
have to remove their blindfold and
navigate the way both the innocent kids
want to volunteer but Mallory is caught
in a dilemma she is not ready to give up
on either of them so after a bit of
consideration Mallory decides that no
one will look they will simply battle
the Rapids and let God decide their
Fates Mallory must be possessed back in
the past both Mallory and Olympia have
gone into labor at the same time while
Tom and Cheryl assist the women upstairs
the suspicious man Gary is doing
something crazy creepy downstairs he
brings out his collection of monster
drawings revealing that he is also
possessed it turns out his main agenda
is to arrive here and infect the others
he is one of the few messengers of the
entity to begin with he puts Mallory's
birds in the refrigerator so that they
don't warn the others then Gary starts
tearing off the newspapers from the
window God damn it Gary meanwhile
Olympia gives birth to a girl and
Mallory to a boy making everyone happy
unfortunately the happiness is
short-lived as Gary barges into the room
and raises the window shades Mallory
quickly looks away but Olympia is not so
lucky she becomes possessed and decides
to commit the unthinkable from the
window but before she can do so she
somehow hands over her daughter to
Mallory after she dies the old woman
Cheryl is forced to open her eyes and
she too dies a painful death just then
Douglas arrives with his gun and manages
to shoot Gary in the arm the two tussle
for a while but in the end Douglas is
also terminated fortunately before the
freak can kill more people Tom finishes
him off with the help of his gun now
it's just him Mallory and the children
left five years passed by and the four
have been living in a secluded house in
the woods even the Birds are alive and
well they have been away from the evils
of the city and the children have become
used to the new environment however they
still don't have any names Tom
criticizes Mallory for the same but she
believes that it is not a priority now
if Kratos can call him boy so can I one
day they hear some noise outside and on
checking find a bunch of infected people
in cars looking for the uninfected this
makes the couple realize that even this
house is unsafe to live in that night as
they are sleeping Mallory's
walkie-talkie suddenly comes to life a
man by the name of Rick starts speaking
from the other side he claims to be in a
secure complex with lots of supplies and
food however reaching there will not be
an easy task Rick explains that they
will have to travel along the river for
several hours while battling the
dangerous Rapids before hanging up he
makes two things clear the river is not
safe for children and the birds are the
key to finding the complex the next
morning the couple discusses the matter
Tom wants to visit the compound but
Mallory is skeptical after the last
incident with Gary she does not want to
believe anyone the same day as the
couple is Scavenging at a nearby house
the infected people again show up
realizing that they don't have enough
time Tom urges Mallory to take the
children and go while he takes care of
the problem the latter is almost brought
to tears but she agrees for the safety
of the children after a while Mallory
packs her belongings and leaves with the
children through the back door while Tom
grabs a gun and goes to face the
infected people he takes down a few of
them before getting shot himself so in
order to finish them all off Tom decides
to take off his blindfold once he does
he turns into a monster and eliminates
all the people one by one then he
commits the unthinkable meanwhile
Mallory and the kids reach home there
she starts briefing them about their
Journey as shown at the start of the
movie in the present it's been 42 hours
and they have finally reached the deadly
Rapids Mallory tries her best to
navigate through the waves but the boat
capsizes and everyone tumbles out
fortunately she is able to grab her kids
and reach the shore unharmed following
this the three slowly start walking
through the woods The Entity also
appears in its invisible form and tries
to manipulate Mallory and the children
into opening their blindfolds however
they ignore him completely and instead
follow the sound of the birds soon they
reach a large compound and Mallory
starts banging on the door like a maniac
fortunately someone opens it and lets
them in after confirming that they are
not infected of course inside they
finally meet Rick who explains that the
compound used to be a skull for the
blind that's why the people here were
never infected Dr lafan is also there
who approaches Mallory and congratulates
her for having such cute children she
asks their names and after a bit of
thinking Mallory says Olympia hence
atreus that Tom the movie ends as she
opens her bird box and lets out the
birds subscribe for more videos like
this turn on notifications and leave a
like to help the channel out thank you
for watching